soyons honnêtes on entend plus souvent
parler d'ingrid chauvin pour des infos
people que pour ses rôles il faut dire
que ces derniers temps il ne s'est pas
passé une seule journée sans qu'une
information sur la crise ne soient
publiques en novembre dernier c'est dans
l'émission la chanson secrètes sur tf1
qu ingrid chauvin s'écrouler en évoquant
son fils tom un cadeau du ciel après la
disparition de sa fille jada âgée de
seulement 5 mois voir son enfant c'est
toujours un miracle pour moi et c'est
toujours quelque chose d'extrêmement
important à mes yeux il ya quelques
jours la star annoncé la sortie d'un
livre événement pour expliquer son
combat face à l'adoption elle qui se dit
privé de ce droit
aujourd'hui c'est en raison du court aux
navires us que l'actrice prend la parole
pour s'agace et du manque de clarté face
au virus
elle qui a été victime d'une double
pneumonie face aux décisions une fois
encore départemental et national
il appartient à chacun d'entre nous de
se responsabiliser face à l'épidémie
bref autant de sorties médiatiques
intime qui s'enchaînent alors selon vous
ingrid chauvin en fait elle trop
voilà ce qu'est pas choquer
effectivement par ingrid chauvin qui se
raconte encore une pâle douloureusement
dans un livre il ya s'étonner guillaume
est choquée m'a d'abord on va écouter
myriam sur l'info et puis à prendre pour
en débattre
mais en fait le truc c'est que moi je
suis choquée parce que je pense qu'elle
n'a pas compris que de sortir ses
bouquins à répétition en fait là
desservait dans sa dans sa procédure
d'adoption
je vous raconte moi je suis passé par
par l'agrément j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'agrément pour adopter en france et les
assistantes sociales ont vraiment
horreur de tout ce qu'elle fait
actuellement cercle il faut il faut dire
que bâle avait sur elle est guérie chose
qu'on a pas là elle a perdu un enfant
est la llc pan elle s'épanche dessus
sans cesse je la comprends et je veux
pas dire que ces voiles à l'adoption si
vous n'avez pas appel de devos et il
faut avoir le fait le deuil de la
maternité pareil elle dit qui a pas
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont adoptables
en france et elle veut changer ça mais
pour que les enfants soit à deux tables
il faut que les parents ne n'est plus de
droits dessus et accepte de laisser
leurs droits ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc et ça l'administration ne pourra
pas dérangé par contre elles avaient
l'opportunité de se mettre en contact
avec des agences étrangères pour pouvoir
adopter à l'étranger et auraient donc
que son coup de gueule il n'est pas il
n'est pas utile en tout cas il est pas
il n'est pas utile je ne sais pas s'il
est pas utile mais en tout cas il n'est
pas utile pour elle ça la dessert plus
qu'autre chose a commenté martin donc
effectivement c'est choquer ou pas entre
guillemets pardon ça peu vulgaire ce
qu'on a fait on appelle ça le la
dépression business mais vous comprenez
ce qu'on vous dire aujourd'hui de l'ailé
star sera compte énormément sur des
sauges très très intime et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui elles vont beaucoup
bouquin là dessus donc est-ce qu'ils
jouent avec un guillaume très choquée
toi moi je ne jugerai jamais la
souffrance d'une mère c'est une femme en
souffrance après j'ai pas raconter ma
vie j'ai été touché un peu comme elle
par park par cette histoire et je j'ai
tendance dans cette période de
transparence absolue il ya plus de
tabous ça me choque un peu c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas exposé d'exposer son
malheur on le garde pour soi moi j'ai
été élevé comme ça c'est peut-être d'une
autre génération tout ça un peu indécent
à se répandre à être réduit à une mère
qui a perdu un enfant
voilà il y en a beaucoup qu'il ya même
quand elle dit que ça peut y en a les
autres qu'ils ont vécu et qui ne s'en
plaignent pas pour autant mais c'est une
façon mais c'est un petit peu tendance à
se parler sans lever le doigt sinon
alors luttons parce que là justement
dans ce livre elle est dans un livre de
combat c'est pas un livre de je me
plains c'est pas les cracks mondiaux
raconter parce qu'il faut quand même
ramené donc à la paire du jeune parce
qu'ils ont la partie donc il faut quand
même le dire qu'elle a perdu cette
petite fille jade après cinq moins de 2
il ya d'autres finalement elle est un
bébé miracle à luton qui sait qu'elle
est devenue heureuse à nouveau et sérail
que tout va bien et qu'elle pourrait
juste par jean ta-100 tous les jours et
qui fait sa vie à cannes non elle se
décide elle a essayé d'aller faire un
agrément avant que son oncle tom soit
arrive dans sa ville avait eu l'agrément
pour l'adoption
finalement comme les hommes ont eu à
aulla refusé d'avoir un enfant massin et
elle parle pour les neuf femmes en
disant moi je veux d'accord que ce soit
plus facile pour tous d'avoir des
enfants de porter
on va faire une fois qu'on a lu que dans
le dans le sens on va dire de
maintenance 8 juste
pardon mais dans l'édition on appelle ça
exploiter un filon mois de sa sincérité
quand elle a fait son premier livre qui
raconte est une vraie souffrance à
perdre un enfant compte en récidive et
qu'on récidive aurait ce niveau autour
de ces sujets là après on exploite un
fils en alors pourquoi l'éditeur constat
c'est très simple c'est une star elle
vend pas mal de bouquins dans quoi elle
mettrait d'un bouquin de page blanche
avec un coloriage elle vendrait autres
brooks et exploiter un filon et cela
décrédibilise qu elle est réduite
maintenant à cette femme qui a eu ce
drame et contes et romans table
j'entends un équilibre parce que moi je
suis un peu partagé mais quand on dit
fortement que des gens comme ça connu
qu'il faut demain nous appartient et
tout ça qui parle au plus grand nombre
en parlant de leur peine finalement se
bat ça peut aussi aider les autres qui
reconnaissait quand c'est basique la
serviette et savait pas cet argument
semble magali latrines et avec tout
l'amour que j'ai pour toi mais comment
tu peux parler de file en ont parle de
gêner que le premier était sincère
eux-mêmes le premier sincère mais
effectivement c'est une histoire c'est
sa mêlée pour moi c'est devenu une icône
elle représente quelque chose c'est un
symbole pour des mamans pour des
familles qui arrivent pas avoir d'enfant
c'est l'adoption c'est la perte d'un
enfant
ensuite c'est la difficulté mais enfin
c'est le cadeau de 2 2 2 ensuite c'est
la difficulté d'acquérir aujourd'hui
l'adoption c'est un non sens vrai
combattant
c'est un vrai problème en prendre mais
il ya des galets au dépanneur
métadonnées à l'étranger et aux y aller
c'est pas facile si c'est parce qu'elle
met l'accent sur sa tous en même temps
par la sauce commence que je vais dire
mais ce que justement le principe des
stars ses poses s'il nous fait est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas possible on
apprend mais c'est pas de la politique
fait d'adopter le nom doit être mélangée
to store doit être secret pour toi c'est
ton opinion l'art elle représente
quelque chose et il vient encore à peine
mieux elle remonte le moral et on en
témoigne la nar elles donnent des
explications des brèches des vraies
choses
non moi je dois dire que j'ai rien
contre effectivement le fait qu'elle
fasse en plus c'est une actrice de télé
donc elle a un rapport de proximité qui
n'a rien à voir dans la finma sauf que
c'est un coup d'éditeurs tu as un
éditeur qui a déjà sorti plusieurs
livres sur le sujet
on a envie d'en sortir un troisième on
va lui demander elle parce que c'est en
fait remarquer filon des singes actuels
économique est à la base du projet dit
rien du tout je ne pensais pas que c'est
vrai que ça intéresse à moi même en vous
écoutant et il bouge un peu au milieu à
tout ce qu'on peut entendre c'est bon
parce que c'est beau si toi tu me dis tu
la connais aussi bien dans la presse
people et non mais aller à l'expo est un
peu le même filon à presse people c'est
à dire que sa feuille tonnes
régulièrement en officielle dans des
magazines comme gala par exemple c'est
un peu à l'américaine
elle n'agit pas comme les mini rien et
je pose une question bien mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est parce que
effectivement on n'est plus dans l'est
le temps avance à l'époque c'était à
janis t de 9 des femmes qui se cachent
en savait rien aujourd'hui bas les stars
effectivement via les réseaux sociaux
via tout ça ce sont des gens
transparence est suffisant ce sont plus
des stars sont des célébrités habitude
pour terminer le coup je suis femme a
pourtant j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
pouriture en plus je suis passé à peu
près par les mêmes choses qu'elle donc
je sais de quoi il parle mais
personnellement moi de là lire dans ses
bouquins et entendent cesser ses
interviews ça m'a pas du tout forfait du
bien et je suis pas sûr que le message
qu'est le déni face moment du bien aux
femmes qui rend compte ce genre de
problème c'est prévu alors donnez moi
j'en passe elle se faisait peut-être du
bien à elle même parce que je sais que
en psychologie c'est toujours bien de de
mettre les mots sur un sur du papier
donc peut-être que c'est pour elle aussi
qu'elle l'a fait avant tout - notamment
j'ai aussi un petit peu aussi de
l'ancienne école j'ai tendance à penser
que ba une star qui devient humaine
c'est pas un an on veut continuer de
rêver j'ai pas envie de savoir
j'ai pas envie de savoir que que la
femme de 2,2 jacques dutronc quand elle
pas chez ruquier bas est la lèpre m2
d'incontinence urinaire tout ça oui mais
on l'est on les a tous on est comme eux
on a tous des problèmes ont vieilli mais
c'est vrai que des stars de nous faire
rêver quand elle vient chez ruquier
qu'elle parle que de ses malheurs à
l'hôpital voilà après chacun son avis
franchement ça m'intéresse d'avoir
l'autre sur internet parce que on n'a
pas toute la vérité